[Musica]
Ci sono voluti circa tre anni per far
capire al mondo che cosa fossero i non
fancible tokens ovvero gli NFC
probabilmente alcuni di voi avranno
visto questa immagine Questa si chiama
Everyday is the first Five thousand Days
dell'artista americano People ovvero My
quickman è un fenomeno interessante
quello della cripto Art che in qualche
modo attraverso la vendita di
quest'opera per oltre 69 milioni di
dollari presso la casa d'asta christie's
a New York Segna in qualche modo
l'entrata della cripto arte all'interno
di quello che è il sistema più ampio
dell'arte contemporanea tradizionale
questo avviene lo scorso marzo del 2021
in qualche modo questa operazione ha
fatto sì che l'arte digitale basata su
blockchain e quindi su una tecnologia
distribuita e immutabile venisse in
qualche modo considerata all'interno di
un sistema più tradizionale Non a caso
lo scorso anno anche il dizionario
britannico Collins decide di intitolare
nft come parola dell'anno cerchiamo di
fare un passo indietro e capire meglio
come il web sia cambiato passando dal
web 1 al web 3 pensiamo al web 1 negli
anni 90 dove credevamo delle pagine in
cui il contenuto veniva caricato in
maniera statica e quindi potevamo
leggere delle informazioni nel web 2
abbiamo visto la comparsa dei blog dove
le nostre informazioni venivano inserite
all'interno di quelli che poi
diventarono i social media Ma chi è
proprietario di quel contenuto nel web 3
vediamo una vera e propria rivoluzione
che attraverso l'utilizzo della
blockchain ci rende proprietari dei
contenuti che andiamo ad inserire su
delle piattaforme
vi porto nel 2018 quando sulla
blockchain di ethereum Viene pubblicata
precisamente nel dicembre il 6 dicembre
del 2018 quest'opera qui che si chiama
Wright
quest'opera viene rilasciata sulla
catena di ethereum da un artista
britannico sconosciuto che va sotto il
nome di X copi Ma nella descrizione di
quest'opera leggiamo testuali parole
perché dovrei comprare quest'opera qui
quando posso semplicemente premere il
tasto destro e scaricarla sul mio
desktop è una domanda molto interessante
che probabilmente molti di voi si
potranno porre Perché comprare una gif
quando posso semplicemente averla a
disposizione gratuitamente
l'artista in qualche modo gioca
ironicamente con la funzione appunto dei
non fangible tokens che cosa hanno fatto
questi nft hanno reso possibile
l'unicità di un file e quindi la sua
proprietà il fatto che gli intermediari
quindi le gallerie o coloro che
rappresentavano gli artisti per la prima
volta venivano esclusi da questo mercato
dando la possibilità agli artisti quindi
uno di avere un guadagno molto più alto
ma a maggior ragione di avere delle
royalties quindi un diritto di seguito
che venisse tracciato in maniera
trasparente attraverso la blockchain
cerchiamo di immaginarla questa
blockchain e di capire quali tipi di
file vengono inseriti Beh sono molti
possiamo pensare appunto a dei JPEG a
delle immagini statiche ma anche a dei
modelli 3D allo stesso tempo a dei video
questa immagine ci fa capire che questa
maglia viene composta e che glienerstesi
in qualche modo sono dei certificati che
contengono dei metadati ma non il
contenuto il contenuto viene in qualche
modo frammentato e distribuito
all'interno di quello che chiamiamo
hipfs interplanetary filesystem Ciò
significa che se tutti noi avessimo dei
computer accesi e avessimo all'interno
dei nostri computer dei piccoli delle
piccole parti di queste file anche se 3
10-15 persone decidono di spegnere
istantaneamente il loro device comunque
l'informazione sarebbe disponibile in
quanto il network è capace di
recuperarla Per questo si trova anche
appunto la definizione di blockchain in
quanto immutabile trasparente e
decentralizzata
ovviamente abbiamo parlato di NT e
cripto Arte Ma esiste anche il metaverso
ed esistono anche altri tipi di asset
possiamo pensare a delle Land Quindi da
appezzamenti di terra virtuali che
possiamo acquistare e gestire Ma
possiamo pensare anche ad un avatar e
pensare anche all'industria del fashion
come i Brand stanno utilizzando questa
tecnologia per rendere il tutto un
pochino più sostenibile
vi porto ancora indietro io vi riporto
all'epoca del Bitcoin quando per la
prima volta nel 2009 Pensate un po'
appare un'immagine un collectable e
quindi non mi sentirei di chiamarla arte
ma più che altro un collectible un
collezionabile appare questa Card che
rappresenta Satoshi nakamoto ovvero il
presunto fondatore di Bitcoin lo
Rappresenta in stile White Collar ma
totalmente colorato di verde perché va a
ricalcare quello che era già presente
nel web come Pepe the Frog che è un Meme
molto conosciuto ed era già venduto su
eBay fino a circa il 2015 questo in
qualche modo viene a esprimersi e a
definire la cripto Art che veniva
commercializzata attraverso dei Canali
telegram e da per la prima volta appunto
associa per la prima volta un asset
visivo con un token digitale
pensiamo quindi a questa tecnologia
questa tecnologia distribuita
immaginiamola appunto come un archivio
nel quale noi possiamo andare a guardare
all'interno di queste cartelle trovare
delle informazioni questa tecnologia non
è centralizzata Ciò significa che non
esiste un nucleo centrale dal quale
partono delle informazioni Ma è una
tecnologia distribuita Ciò significa che
ciascuno di noi può inserire delle
informazioni e queste informazioni
saranno pertanto immutabili abbiamo
sentito parlare di enective come questi
possono essere Bruciati cosa significa
non significa che questi verranno
rimossi ma Pensiamo un po' alle ceneri
della Fenice in qualche modo resteranno
per sempre le tracce della presenza di
quello che abbiamo scritto sulla
blockchain
questa ad esempio è una rappresentazione
grafica dell'artista exity in cui ci
rappresenta il primo nodo della catena
di Bitcoin vediamo una stringa di codice
alfanumerica che è appunto un Ash e
questa è una rappresentazione grafica
questo per dirvi cosa che la blockchain
è infinita ma ha avuto un origine e
questa è la rappresentazione della sua
Genesi
ora Certamente viviamo tutti la crisi
energetica e sappiamo quanto sia
difficile ad oggi sopperire a tale crisi
il Bitcoin così come le trion sono stati
criticati per essere altamente
consuma energetico molto molto elevato
ma voglio darvi una buona notizia lo
scorso 15 settembre la catena di
ethereum che è una delle catene usate
principalmente nel settore della cripto
arte ha dato avvio al tanto auspicato
merge ovvero all'Unione e alla
differenziazione di due sistemi se prima
si parlava di prof work ora si parla di
prof Stake andrò a spiegarvi la
differenza
nel prof work avevamo tanti computer in
delle Warehouse che dovevano fare una
sorta di staffetta computazionale in cui
Diciamo che c'era un consumo abbastanza
elevato di energia nel prof Stake
utilizziamo i token sono delle valute
digitali che possono avere una sorta di
conversione anche in valuta corrente o
meno e questi vengono adoperati da noi
umani per approvare i cosiddetti blocchi
quindi per fissare queste informazioni
all'interno della blockchain questo
sistema ha fatto risparmiare a livello
di impatto energetico oltre il 95%. per
cui fare Un ernia ad oggi non è più così
energivoro
vi faccio vedere una rappresentazione
grafica di come il prof work e il prof
Stake sono state create come NFC da un
artista oggi e quindi un original
Gangster uno dei primissimi che si è
espresso in questa categoria della
criptoarte e qui lo vediamo in piedi e
quindi anche la postura cambia Per farci
capire appunto come l'uscita da questa
caverna possa in qualche modo creare una
nuova sostenibilità per questa
tecnologia
abbiamo parlato di token e ora vi porto
a conoscenza di una nuova modalità di
token e di quello che ad oggi chiamiamo
dao organizzazioni autonome e
decentralizzate i token possono avere un
valore commerciale Come dicevamo posso
acquistare dei token convertirli
scambiarli benissimo Ci sono anche altre
categorie di token che sono Soul bound
Forse alcuni di voi hanno giocato a
World of Warcraft Beh lì il primo
concetto di sold out token viene
affermato che vuol dire il soulbound è
legato alla nostra anima Ciò significa
che se io agisco o faccio delle azioni
benevole nei confronti della comunità
aumenterò il livello del mio karma e
quindi acquisirò un reward traducibile
in token questi token non sono
trasferibili ma sono di nostra proprietà
ciò dà un impatto diverso rispetto a
come le dao possono funzionare queste
organizzazioni appunto autonome
decentralizzate che possiamo vedere qui
rappresentati come un albero con diversi
gettoni danno la possibilità a delle
aziende così come hanno fatto delle
piattaforme di creare una struttura
totalmente diversa rispetto a quella
centralizzata quindi un'organizzazione
distribuita in cui le persone che
vogliono partecipare attivamente allo
sviluppo di queste piattaforme o
organizzazioni possono farlo attraverso
un sistema di voto vi faccio degli
esempi se in un sistema Democratico una
testa equivale a un voto Quindi tutti
noi abbiamo lo stesso diritto e potere
di voto in un sistema tokencratico un
token equivale ad un voto
Ma vitalic buterin che è stato il
cofondatore della catena di ethereum
fa un'unione di queste due cose ideando
un nuovo sistema chiamandolo quadratic
voting o anche voto plurale Ciò
significa che il mio quantitativo di
token che Possiedo all'interno del mio
Wallet facciamo un esempio 100 deve
essere fratto e quindi la radice
quadrata del quantitativo dei miei token
sarà il mio potere nella votazione di un
proposal ad esempio questo che cosa Crea
crea una sorta di meritocrazia ovvero
riduce il GAP che c'è tra chi possiede
molti token e chi ne possiede di meno se
io ne posseggo 100 appunto il mio voto
sarà 10 ma se ne posseggo un over nel
mio moto sarà 3 Pertanto il GAP si
riduce questa cosa è abbastanza
rivoluzionaria e c'è un professore
associato di informatica dell'università
di Udine che sta sperimentando un
sistema Dau applicato all'educazione
Chiama appunto dae decentualise
autonomous educa Generation queste
organizzazioni che possono funzionare
all'interno di sistemi scolastici dando
la possibilità a coloro che apprendono
di scegliere insieme organicamente al
proprio tutor al proprio insegnante
quali materie per esempio affrontare e
dando loro anche dei Rewards
token dando così un incentivo diverso
rispetto alla tradizionale
organizzazione di voto che di norma è
più verticale quindi attuando un sistema
orizzontale si può creare un diverso
movimento che che lega l'educazione e le
dao a qualcosa di concreto che possiamo
far parte tutti noi
è arrivato il momento di
di fare un'azione vi chiedo di prendere
il vostro cellulare quindi vi do un
attimo per farlo
e di inquadrare questo QR Code
come vedrete questo bellissimo mi metto
un attimo qua spero riuscite ad
inquadrarlo questa bellissima
illustrazione fatta dall'artista Kelly
romandi e creata appositamente per The
Dex Vicenza rende possibile a tutti voi
l'acquisizione del vostro primo Chissà
nfd è un podcast per per essere più
precisi un profugo a tendance una sorta
di biglietto digitale che testimonia la
vostra partecipazione a questo evento e
questa è una delle tante magie del Web 3
il fatto che possiamo condividere
attraverso l'utilizzo della blockchain
un'esperienza che abbiamo fatto e
abbiamo condiviso tutti quanti noi oggi
ringrazio Kelly e tutti voi per questa
per questo Talk Grazie
[Applauso]